ces images de vidéosurveillance des voix
l'instant où les bombardements russes se
sont abattues aux abords de la centrale
nucléaire de zaporijia très rapidement
deux bâtiments sont touchés par un
incendie les responsables du site
affirme que tout est sous contrôle
les pompiers ukrainiens ont pu y accéder
mais la situation est confuse l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
assure que l'équipement essentiel est
épargné les niveaux de radioactivité
inchangé pourtant le président ukrainien
allen ce qui lance un avertissement
l'europe de se réveiller maintenant la
plus grande centrale nucléaire d'europe
est en flammes
les tanks russes cible des réacteurs
nucléaires ce sont des tanks équipé de
caméras thermiques
ils savent donc exactement où il tire
ici était préparé retour à côté
ukrainien
des centaines d'hommes étaient
rassemblés ce jeudi au centre de la
défense territoriale de sa politique des
volontaires venus entre autres défendre
la centrale nucléaire très proche dit si
elle est assiégée entouré par les forces
russes depuis mercredi des centaines de
volontaires et c'est de la défendre le
site et de l'autre côté de cette rive il
contient six réacteurs sur les quinze
que compte l'ukraine un lieu hautement
stratégique fondamentale pour l'économie
du pays comme l'expliquent le maire
vous vous rendez compte les résumant
bombarde en ce moment la ville alors que
nous avons ici la plus grande centrale
nucléaire d'europe
l'europe menacée directement dans sa
sécurité par les actions de poutine
déplore boris johnson le premier
ministre britannique qui a appelé à une
réunion d'urgence du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu la maison blanche de son côté a
exhorté la russie à cesser ses activités
militaires dans la zone